one of the things I've seen you mention
is you know nice guys and uh you know I
mean I was definitely conditioned
programmed to be you know a nice humble
faithful uh
Guy
and
um you know as I look back to my when I
first kind of was finding my way on my
own first year at
University I just my just by just by
virtue of being
nice I got into situ I got into really
dangerous situations you know um I
happened to be going to the University
of Utah in Salt Lake City and and where
I was living at one point I didn't know
it but it was like if you're out at
night this is where all the gay guys are
hanging out and they're they're on the
prow you know and I had no idea and you
know being such a nice guy like there
was so much of the world so much of the
world that I was just not even uh aware
of um but
what not that that's what we're here to
talk about but what is it that uh nice
guys don't understand about women
relationship marriage divorce these
sorts of
things um that by not understanding that
can get them in trouble or lead to a a
terrible
divorce well you know culture and
Society tells men and women different
things they tell men do what's right
they tell women you do what's right for
you girl so that might sound the same
but they're totally different men are
disposable we've always been disposable
it's why women and children were off the
Titanic first and most of the men
drowned right um that's just a feature
of humanity it's not a bug it's just
what
creates uh more children and adults you
know if you preserve women and children
then you're then you're going to further
the benefit of culture and Society um
but I think that there's a lot of nice
guys that are manufactured today and I
think there's a difference between Nice
Guys and kind men I think uh you know
being a kind man is is uh you know might
sound similar but again it's different
like nice guys create these covert
contracts in their head uh Dr Robert
Glover wrote a book called No More Mr
Nice Guy and essentially that's you know
what it all boils down to is you invest
in these ideas in your mind you you know
you create an agreement between you
let's say you know you uh you meet a g
you like her you mirror her you know you
put a ring on her finger and some babies
in her you know sort of thing and
because you're a nice guy you know you
create this covert contract in your head
that if you just man up do the right
thing uh you know take the kids to all
their extracurriculars uh empty the
dishwasher load it up cut the grass that
you're going to have a nice productive
loving uh enthusiastically you know
sexual productive like sort of marriage
sort of thing and it doesn't work that
way because that's not how women are run
that's not what keeps them U interested
and attracted to men um it just doesn't
work in that in that nice guy sort of
concept um well I think it's a great way
to sort of simplify it things um you
know for for men to understand that they
shouldn't be nice men they should be
kind men they should be good men they
should be good at being men but being
nice is doesn't doesn't really serve you
as a guy in life nice guys get destroyed
in Family Court uh you know being nice
or being chivalrous is not the time to
to uh use that little life strategy in a
divorce you know for example you know um
so there's a time and a place I guess
for maybe niceness but but at the end of
the day I think men need to tune in a
little bit more to their inner
um and you know subscribe to the notion
that
without men or daddy being happy in the
household nobody's going to be happy
right so you know we used to have
we used to have a lot of authority in a
household you know with a family and in
a relationship we still have
responsibilities you know we have
responsibility to protect preside you
know you know provide and pull our end
of the uh bargain um but we don't have a
lot of authority any more I think it's
you know because guys have turned into
nice guys you know it's where we you
know hear a lot of terms you know
today's and sound bites that I think a
lot of your audience will pick up on
once they start to listen to like the
word partner you know for example um
part gets thrown around a lot and I
don't buy it it's it's husband wife it's
boyfriend girlfriend it's not partner
you're not Partners in a law firm you're
not Partners in a business you're not
equal and exactly the same men and women
are different and you know trying to
blur the lines you know between the
Sexes and equalize things and make men
less so women can become more um you
know there's certain things that are
never going to change like the notion
that men are disposable and that women
are protected that's always going to
exist but I think that men need to be
more of a man you know they need to be
good at being men and letting go of the
nice guy persona because it just doesn't
serve you you're not gonna become
wealthy being a nice guy Jeff bezel is
not a nice guy Elon Musk is not a nice
guy right like these guys created
massive Legacy and fortunes you know for
themselves and the shareholders that
invested in their business not by being
nice guys maybe by being kind men to
some regard but the nice guy notion
won't get you anywhere in life in my
estimation I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out